(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Good to see you.
- [Kyra] Thank you.
(audience continues cheering)
- I know. I know.
I've been very excited.
I'm now meeting the whole
family except Travis,
but I've met Sosie now, I've met him
and I'm very excited to meet you.
- Thank you.
- I'm like a big fan.
- Do you guys get into
March Madness? We were
talking about it earlier.
- Since I didn't go to college
I don't have much skin in the
game for any particular team
but I do like to catch up to it
and that's when I start watching
and I fill out a bracket
and, you know...
- Yeah.
- I was trying to explain
in the dressing room, Kyra was like
"What's a bracket?".
- A bracket? What's a bracket?
- Oh you're me. So now I know,
but my friends are really into sports ball
so I had to do it.
And then I usually pick like
favorite colors or mascots
and then I just go with it. (laughing)
I get a part. It's like they
eliminate each other each time.
I know a little bit more now.
Well wait, this is gonna
be, is it 35 years?
- [Kyra] Yes.
- So you're about to celebrate
35 years together?
- Yes
(audience cheering)
- That's incredible.
- Well...
I'm just saying it doesn't always happen,
especially for people in the business,
especially for two artists.
Like, that's incredible.
Let me know like what your secret is.
Maybe I'll use it next time, like yeah.
- We have no secret
- We have no secrets, yes.
- Are y'all doing
anything big? Are you doing
anything to celebrate?
- We don't usually do a big
thing for our anniversary.
We usually like hang out
and go to dinner, you know.
I mean, really we're--
- Yeah.
- [Kevin] We make dinner.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- We're pretty boring.
- But that's nice.
But I feel like our jobs
are always constantly going
and doing stuff, so it's nice to do--
- [Kyra] Yes exactly.
Exactly, exactly.
- Yeah.
- I think one of the things we like
about our anniversary
though, I have to say,
is that it falls in September
and I absolutely love the
month of September because it--
- [Kelly] Ooh, fall in general.
- Yeah. I mean, the light is so beautiful.
And also, for some reason New Years
is supposed to be the start of the year
but it never feels like the
start of the year for me.
September feels like when the year starts.
It's hopeful.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience coos)
And you think that
coincides with like school--
- Is that corny I don't know I--
- No, do you think that--
- I wasn't even trying
to elicit an aw but somehow
just talking about September
got an aw.
- For my family
it's because I have kids.
So it's like school starts around then.
- [Kyra] Yes. Yes, exactly.
- Yeah, right.
- So it feels like the school
year kind of starts for me too.
In a totally non-romantic way.
- Exactly.
- Just that's when I buy school supplies.
So, that's what it is.
- Yes exactly.
- So when Kevin was here he had a story
about you hating your engagement ring.
- [Kyra] Oh God.
- Which I love.
- Ugh.
- So is this true?
- You loved her engagement ring?
- No. I love the story of her being--
You knew y'all were gonna
make it when she could be
that level of honest.
- That's right. That's right.
It took me like two weeks
to be that level of honest.
- Two weeks?
It would've taken me years.
- (laughing) Right?
- Yeah. That's honesty though.
Like, that's amazing that you, yeah.
- It was pretty intense.
It's one of those things where you like--
I knew that you had spent a
lot of time looking for it,
just the right one.
And, you know, I looked at it
and every time I looked at it,
I was like, "This isn't
me. This isn't right."
- Yeah.
- And so we...
I had to, you know, one
night we went to sleep
and he falls asleep in about 30 seconds.
And I sort of was rolling
around and I turned on the light
and I was like, "I gotta say it",
I turned on the light, I woke
up and he's like, "What?"
And I said, "I'm so sorry.
I love you so much, but I
really don't like the ring."
And he was like,
(laughing)
"Oh my God! I thought it
was something serious!"
And then the next morning he was like,
"I feel really bad that
you don't like the ring."
- Oh.
- "I worked really hard
trying to find it." And
I felt bad, but you know,
better to do it then.
- No. Better to be honest.
- Just rip off the bandaid.
- This is the secret.
- Rip off.
- Right off the bat.
- Yes. Exactly.
- I love it.
(audience coos)
I love that you were like two weeks.
(chuckles) It would take me two years.
I love that.
Their new film is called "Space Oddity."
Kyra directed it and Kevin stars in it.
So Kyra, why did you
wanna make this movie?
Because you were choosing
to direct something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- On the face of it's a
really beautiful story
about a young man who
grew up on a flower farm
and decides that in his twenties
he wants out of the Earth
and he wants to go to Mars.
So he thinks he's training
for a one way journey to Mars.
And basically he lives with
his family on this flower farm
and he falls in love with
a young woman in the town
and then ends up not going.
So that's like the surface of it, right?
- Yeah.
- It's funny, it's sad,
it's hopeful, but ultimately
it's really about grief
and about how when we grieve
and when we've lost someone
and when something happens
that's painful in our life,
sometimes we scatter away from each other
and away from the world and
we wanna just check out.
And he's checking out in a major way
by wanting to go to Mars,
but we all check out, right?
- Yeah.
- And this is a family
that's coming to terms
with the loss of a child.
And so they're all checking
out in one way or another
and they have to come back together.
And it's basically about
fighting the good fight
here on Earth.
Life is messy. Life is
sad, things are scary,
people die, the Earth
is struggling right now,
but we have to try and
make a go of it here.
There isn't a planet B.
There's no planet B.
- Yeah.
There's no like...
You know, we need each other.
- Yeah.
- And so, that's ultimately--
it had so many great
messages and such great fun
and romance and like...
- Yeah.
- So many great things
about it that I was
like, "This is the one."
- What a great teaser.
That was incredible.
- Thank you.
- Yeah. Well, I wanna talk about your son,
'cause I think I think this is so cool.
So Travis does music.
- Yes.
- And how did he
get involved with the film?
- Yeah, Travis is a great musician,
has been from the time he was...
I mean, he had the
first guitar in his hand
when he was like eight or
something, or maybe even younger.
And he did the music for my first movie
for my first movie
called "Story of a Girl."
He said, you know, "I have some ideas."
He read the script, he was like
"I've got some ideas for theme and score.
I mean, I'll just give it a
shot and see what you think."
And I'm like, "Okay."
'Cause I just didn't know.
- Yeah.
- You thought you were
gonna have to turn him down.
- Yeah, I did, I did.
- Yeah.
- And then it was incredible.
- Oh wow!
- And then he did "Space Oddity"
which is a whole nother vibe.
- Yeah.
- And no, he's incredible,
he's a really great composer.
- It's a beautiful thing though,
you don't think about how many
people go into each episode
of a show or a movie.
You don't think about
all those people that are
in the background making
this one scene happen.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
- It's a really magical thing
that y'all get to be a part of.
- Yeah.
Anyway, I was just gonna say that.
Well, sometimes the family
plays music with goats.
So, quick question.
Why?
(laughter)
- [Kyra] Good question.
- [Kelly] Like what? (chuckles)
- [Kevin] The goats showed
up, we've had a farm
for a long time.
- (laughing) This is awesome.
- (chuckling) Playing
a little ukulele there.
- I had pygmies once.
Like they're, I love goats.
- [Kevin] Yeah goats are awe--
- They will eat everything though, yes.
- Yeah, no they're great.
That's...
- They will eat your clothes.
- That was Hocus and Little Man.
Yeah.
We had a farm for a really long time
and always had big horses.
But on our anniversary,
actually I think it was
during the pandemic.
- [Kyra] Yeah.
- I snuck out and went and got
a couple of miniature goats,
pygmies, and stuck them
in one of the stalls
and then said "Happy Anniversary".
And took her down and
introduced her to these goats.
And one day I was just
fooling around and went down
and took an instrument down
there and just started playing.
And I don't know,
(chuckling) they seemed like
they liked it. (laughing)
- You're like, "I'm a
hit here." (laughing)
- Yeah.
- Right. Nobody else
is gonna listen to me.
(laughing)
So I'll let the goats.
- I totally sing to my animals.
I was being funny when I said
"why" but I totally do it too.
- Yeah. I mean they're very soothing.
- Not like too them almost,
just like, kind of with them,
and then they sit there
while you're loving on them.
- Yeah.
- It's very soothing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean, it's soothing
for us to be with them.
- Exactly.
- And then,
you know, music has the same thing.
So then I just took it
and started picking songs
that I thought, and started
this series called "Goat Songs."
And sometimes Kyra's been there with me
and sometimes Sosie and yeah,
we've done a lot of them.
- Yeah.
- I love your family so much.
(chuckling) It's so random.
I love it so much.
Well, later we actually have music
from one of the organizations
that you guys worked with.
We're super excited about it.
But we need to take a quick break.
"Space Oddity" is in
theaters starting today
and on demand so go see it.